uh nintendo power fest 1990
now look it's a long video but i wanted
to really focus in on one guy i'm gonna
back up just a little bit so you can
kind of see what's going on in nintendo
power fest this is just raw footage
but trust me you're gonna find the alpha
male very soon
so uh yeah as you can see
playing some uh super super mario
brothers
[Music]
and this guy here he is check this guy
out look at this guy set up
[Music]
look at this guy look at this guy's rig
rate my rig
chin strap so just hold his chin up okay
then he's got his straw so he can drink
his drink so he doesn't get thirsty
there it is this is his drink okay then
he's got his controller
on it
[Music]
now this guy this guy's cool
takes a little while to get this
[Music]
adjusted
[Music]
this is the ideal mail you may not like
it
but this is what it looks like this is
what the ideal mail looks like
sit there
you be upset and you're right this guy
definitely follows nick fuentes
but say whatever you want but there's
one thing that you can't deny
there's one thing that you know that you
can't deny okay
50 s with you
guys this is the guy in the house doing
all the [ __ ] am i right you know i'm
right
this guy [ __ ] thanks
this he does this guy [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my god so the liquid isn't the thing
he made itself i'm trying to
really let's let's piece this together
here i really want to try to see if we
can figure this out
so the liquid is inside a compartment
inside his what are the knobs for
because we know the controller we know
the controllers up there the controllers
up there in the top right
but what are the knobs for does that
adjust the speed
or maybe the flow of the water and is it
water
or is it mountain dew i need to know how
cool this guy is
1990 is it jolt cola
is he drinking jolt cola i need to know
what's happening the liquid look clear
so it's probably water
i can't i can't i can't
i can't
my god holy [ __ ]
holy holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] man that's
pretty cool
maybe it's clear pepsi you're right it's
1990 it could be clear messy
oh oh clear pepsi was 1992 alright maybe
he was an early adopter maybe they gave
maybe give him some beta
testing of it he does
kind of look like jeffrey dahmer jeffrey
dahmer at the nintendo [ __ ] world
championships
at the nintendo power fest
[ __ ] what's he doing
oh [ __ ] am i crystal pepsi
you're right maybe he sucks means right
maybe he's sucking up that infamous
internet cast everyone's talking about
um all i want to see is this oh good
it's for a while too perfect
thank god
he needs an adjustment his chin strap
isn't his little chin holder isn't
working right
he needs to adjust it
[Music]
wait wait wait wait wait wait hold on
hold on a second that's not a drink
he's playing with his mouth
holy [ __ ] this is a new level
oh what the [ __ ] he's actually playing
so this is like for but you have hands
is this for a paraplegic
this is even better
out of the way power glove we have a new
interface
[Music]
he died
[Music]
he's trying it again
[Music]
yeah i think you're right the d-pad is
just chin okay
[Music]
yeah but beat halo legendary with it
[Music]
that's a good point he said he could
play it as he could play well fair
enough
[Music]
all right that's your name interview
this one
brian your game counselor tell me about
how you got to be
one well he's a game counselor [ __ ]
awesome
i was managing restaurants and i saw an
at the paper
wanting uh asking if you want to play
video games for a living
and from that you know i gave him a call
nintendo up basically a little known
company
gave him a call set up interview came in
they liked my style they liked my
background and computers and
my video game skills uh and went from
there
okay no it's it we've actually watched
the background on this we've watched the
training videos and how this actually
works before
older a-wave episodes what we have they
just have you sit they have you walk in
and they have you sit down
and all you have to do is you have to
read you have to read
game guide after game guide after game
guide and
just play video games along with them
that's all you do it doesn't take a
genius to do this
tell me what that you had tried other
things and
those didn't work and okay well uh well
i prostituted myself i was a
gigolo for a little while um i also
started trying to i started a business
where i collected women's hair and
turned it into dolls
that didn't work out super well for me
and uh i also sold that monavie
uh wine or juice thing it was a pyramid
scheme it turned out
and but you know right now i'm gonna do
this and i'm hearing this this company
come along called enron and i think i'm
gonna invest big into them
managing restaurants uh was was my
biggest successful but i
managed quite a few of them pizza
parlors basically
you didn't okay i'm sorry you did okay
hold on you didn't manage a restaurant
okay you didn't manage a
a high-end dining establishment okay you
weren't managing a
a steakhouse you know or your manager of
a high-end restaurant you can make some
good money
you weren't managing them you were
managing a not even a pizza hut
but a lo that you were you were the
manager at a local pizza place
restaurant manager could very widely
depending on what
kind of restaurant you're doing you know
you're not you're not imagining a fine
dining establishment where you have to
go in with a suit
you're going you're you're managing a
[ __ ] goodzoli's get the [ __ ] out of
here
i'll last about a year at each one just
couldn't keep do they close down or a
new management come in
well i mean technically i wasn't a
manager
i was actually a server but they said i
was a manager in training
well i mean technically i wasn't a
manager in training
but i told people i was a manager in
training because like i wanted to think
better of me
am i right eric i also worked
as a firefighter oh god a second
this keeps getting better and better
it was a firefighter
you imagine the firefighter calendar
with this guy in it ladies
this guy was a firefighter
you [ __ ] imagine this guy trying to
axe open a door this guy
this dude
[Laughter]
he's a hero guys you're right he's a
first responder
management come in i also worked as a
firefighter
a slash burning firefighter
i was in the air force for a little
while as a cop in the air force security
police
but you were in the air force for a
while
so he was he wasn't a [ __ ] mp is that
what he was
so he was in the air force i have a
feeling i was in the air force for a
while but he's not anymore
probably get dishonorably discharged
this is your typical air force guy look
i don't even pick military branches
because i know how much you military
people like to make fun of each other
but i gotta say now you [ __ ] the army
dudes and the marine dudes
and the navy dudes have something have
something more
to make fun of for the air force guys
hey this is your typical air force guy
but uh video games or at least computers
where i
basically have been uh headed for and
now this guy's the guy that's probably
censoring your speech online so i mean
really he got the last laugh
since my dad works with computers for
the government
it's always been the guy the dad works
for computers for the government
there we go yep
a techno winnie's uh uh nightmare
for a family life so so do you tell me
you you do have to be computer
illiterate yeah you have to be computer
leader you have to
know something about computers uh
at least how a computer works uh what a
program is
uh what a bit megabytes uh even
simple stuff is uh you don't have to
know about computers to walk somebody
through a game
shut up as a menu at nintendo
we have two types of computer systems we
have the nintendo gaming system that we
the game councils play all the time and
what the kids play
but then also we have one called elmo
it's called electronic
uh manual system operating system
basically
right now he now he flies predator
drones michael's right
he flies predator drones and [ __ ]
bombs hospitals it's
a computer system that all game
counselors
must learn to learn to use because
that's where all their information is
we all don't memorize the information
about
games no you have [ __ ] the mag the
nintendo powers in front of you
stop making your shitty little stupid
part-time job sound more important than
it
actually is we have to use it it's an
ibm
style computer to retrieve that
information to tell the consumer
where they need to go into a game that's
the game counselor's best friend
now um what do you like best about your
job
i get a smell girl's hair it's pretty
cool
i walk up to them and i'm like hey let
me show you to hold the controller and
then i
smell their hair i've been kicked out of
a lot of sears
do you have that demo thing where people
could play video games and i just walk
up and i just smell the girl's hair
and then they say sir you need to leave
and then i tell him i was in the navy
and my girlfriend actually lives in
canada
and i'm a manager in training at a
[ __ ] pizza joint
about my job is uh seeing the games
first
playing the new games and seeing what
what future
uh technology i guess for the nintendo
system is on the horizon what's coming
out in the future and seeing for the
first time
um playing with new devices and get
gadgets that our engineering staff
dreams up
our engineering stuff again
he answers a 1 900 number to help walk
people through the legend of zelda
and he's saying our engineering staff at
nintendo yes because i'm sure the
engineers in japan and nintendo
know about you dahmer uh that's the
fun part of it uh just being around uh
future technology i guess is the biggest
part of what i enjoy about the
about working at nintendo and talking to
the kids and telling them about this new
information i wouldn't want this guy
talking to kids
or new games or new devices that will be
coming for the nintendo in the future
now do you spend time on the phone lines
as well have you done that
oh yes oh yes when i first started
working there i'd spend eight to ten
hours on the phones
uh five sometimes six days a week so you
so
so again like i said he he's on the
phone
walking people through legend of zelda
that that's what he's doing
i'm a workaholic uh lately of course
before i came on this tour basically i
was working about three maybe four hours
i had other projects too some game
counselors work on projects for
uh marketing for licensing uh they might
work what do you do
our magazine staff or research and
development they might be playing a game
for
10 hours a day just to see if there any
bugs in it and
help debug games so you were a game
tester
are game counselors wizards are you a
wizard i consider myself a wizard
[Laughter]
um
oh my god oh my god he considers himself
a wizard guys
he considers himself a wizard don't
worry i got it
[Music]
darren of nintendo's just leveled up
[Music]
hey can one of your photoshop guys do me
a favor and take this
and do the sneak increase 100 please
thank you add more stuff if you want if
one of you
crazy people please do the sneak
increase with this guy this guy's my
hero now
i have a new hero and it's this guy
[Music]
wow
yeah photoshop guys what i'm a boomer
who cares uh marketing for
licensing uh they might work for for the
power magazine staff or
research and development they might be
playing a game for 10 hours a day
just to see if there any bugs in it and
help debug games
so are our game counselors wizards are
you a wizard
you know sneaking like sneaked increased
one like you know from the game skyrim
i meant you know to make it look like he
just leveled up in skyrim i'm sorry i
have to be specific here to people don't
understand what i was asking for
i think most of you did
be nice to him this is what they stole
from us did they
i'm fine with the thing i'm taking this
i consider myself a wizard
uh howard phillips might think he might
not think that way
but we're wizards um we are
you might say idols to some of these
kids uh when
here on the tour a lot of kids who would
ask this [ __ ] for an autograph
idols be nice to him this is what they
stole from his idols to what kids
i want to say we're as big as rock stars
or some sports stars
but for some of these kids a nintendo uh
they not only have nintendo's but they
have computers and they're the other
side of
i guess
all right somebody did actually send me
a photo of him
give me a second here
oh god give me a sec i found it i i just
it was sent to me like
quickly all right here it is
somebody did send me a photo of what
he's doing now i guess you guys still
around
i guess that's cool um
here he is uh this is him now and look i
want to apologize
he is technically a wizard there he is
this is what he looks like
now um he is still a wizard
um not so much the gaming kind
but a wizard nonetheless let me look at
the ropes
so i mean still doing it
he's still doing it hey if you love what
you do you'll never work a day in your
life that's what they say if you love
what you do
you'll never work a day in your life
anyway go back to this guy some of these
kids that like sports or collect uh
baseball cards or sports cards
or play baseball or football they like
to dabble in computer work and then
nintendo was probably the first thing
that
happened in their life before they were
able to get like their own computer
and what do you think i mean how would
you characterize these
kids is what they're doing spending
hours and hours and hours on these games
well he's grand level he's a grand
wizard i talk to a lot of kids
probably shouldn't ones that are really
hardcore into it that i talk to and i
become friends too
while talking on the phones i mean don't
though can you not
not only do they have a nintendo but
like i said they also have a computer
system they'll send us cards
printed off their printer and it'll be a
complete comic book they'll make a one
kid sent a complete comic book that he
designed
using his macintosh his own macintosh he
does computer programming
cool boys right if you're white never
call yourself a wizard
he was uh 12 i believe now 13 years old
and he's uh he's more he's better than i
am on a computer doing
programs we're running a computer uh the
kid is in there
he knows how to do like cd space than
the doom directory and then he types
doom.exe
he's pretty smart he lives in san jose
california i can't remember his name but
we talked to a lot of these kids and
nintendo is their life
but also computers are their lives and
they're always asking us
how do we become game counselors or how
do you program a game and we always
refer them to their local community
community college
or their high school their counselor in
high school
good point if you tweet a racial slur
you'll also never work a day in your
life
either way you're not working junior
high uh
get information on uh how a computer
operates or take programming classes we
talk to a lot of kids that are
learning the program just because of
nintendo so how do you become a gamer
you know like yeah he's pretty good
you're right when he copy when he does
copy paste he doesn't like
he he actually just does control c
control v he is like
next level tech genius well of course
you have to live in seattle area
and work i'd rather not i would rather
not
constantly hiring and training it's a
tough training program we go we now go
through compared to when i started three
years ago but now we have a regimen and
training program
you have to be consumer oriented of
course that's your first thing is you
have to be able to talk to people
be able to convey information in a
timely manner to the consumer and let
them
make it understandable to them then of
course comes we can make anybody a game
counselor
we can teach anybody all the tips so it
shows you that um
your job isn't a hard one if if any look
like
not anybody can become a brain surgeon
you know
not anyone could become an electrical
engineer
not anyone could work for the [ __ ] uh
work work on building rocket ships not
everyone could be a rocket scientist
if anyone could be a game counselor
anyone could also work at mcdonald's and
anyone could [ __ ] work at a grocery
store
you're not really doing high-level stuff
here bud the tricks
the ins and outs of all the games but
it's uh being personable
and being yeah ben carson did and now
he's dead
mustard tiger take that
uh consumer oriented i guess obviously
what is the test that you have to go
through
the test the test consists of a couple
of trainers
making you play a game and you're
writing about that game
you sit down you'll write a paragraph
about what you liked what you disliked
about the game
what you felt could be improved upon the
game belting looked at
look at that sit down with you talk to
you find out what other
skills you have it might be computer
skills it might be so wait a second all
you have to do is write a paragraph
summation of a game
how is this different than being a
[ __ ] game reviewer for ign
the games you've already learned while
playing the nintendo system
uh from then on if you're hired on which
it doesn't take a whole lot to get hired
on as a game counselor they're openings
if you're able to pass a simple test
like
writing a paragraph you're into our
training program and it's about six
weeks
and it's uh learning the top ten games
that are out there and the questions
that we get on and this is constantly
getting tested every day
quest every day we call round tables you
sit down and uh the train
uh thank you so much weirdo cast this is
all i was asking for i wasn't asking for
anything difficult
and i appreciate it thank you so much
very simple
thank you weirdo cast who made this
sneaky kid's bedroom maybe
um
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
this is [ __ ] a wizard dude we'll fire
questions
and you're going to answer them and
you're graded on this we take it very
seriously
we don't want someone out there giving
out wrong information we want everybody
giving out the right correct information
and uh it's six weeks it's hard work we
consider hard work a lot of people
don't make it through the through the
training program for one reason or
another
but the ones that do they're game
counselors and they're one of the few
thank you okay okay
[Music]
oh my god look at this place
this thing had everything oh my god
it had a guy that looked like mark
summers and that
super mario was there and [ __ ]
robocop
this thing had everything
this is [ __ ] awesome
this is awesome you're right no i mean
as a kid
in 1990 i was i was eight i would have
been flipping out
flipping out
all right i need your guy's help to find
the game master i hear he's about five
foot ten he wears a little weird bow tie
and he's got red hair okay so let's all
fan out robo why don't you go that
way mario you go that way i'm going to
go this way all right good luck
i don't want you to have your back
a little bit okay all right my back
totally to the camera
is that good oh these are all outtakes
all right all right all right i need
your guys help to find the game master
okay i hear he's about five foot ten he
wears a little weird bow tie and he's
got red hair
let's fan out robo why don't you go that
way mario you go that way and i'm gonna
go this way all right
good luck here we go
a weird little bow tie he's got red hair
so let's fan out robo wanted robo just
pulls his gun out and shoots the guy
that way mario go that way i'll go this
way okay
great
how many takes how many takes do we need
walking away
so this is all the raw footage from abc
okay
hold on
here we go we got we got a little bit
more excited
mario did you spot him what do you mean
mario's probably not doing great with
that mask on
[Music]
you know i do find it kind of funny that
robocop was at like
at this event and it's mostly because
robocop was a [ __ ] rated arm movie it
was
brutal it was [ __ ] brutal
and it was just a kid's toy which was
fine i mean i had a robocop toy when i
was a good too but
it's just funny like that the kids loved
that movie even though it was rated r
i guess matt smith was there the 11th
doctor was also there apparently don't
buy any of this
[Music]
these kids must have been having a
goddamn blast though huh
that's uh it's pretty creepy there dude
version of a real-life city my favorite
one the simpsons which is modeled after
that famous tv family
the problem is i have no time to play
any of these new games like mario i have
to move on to the next world
in my continuing search for the game
master
oh so this is just them all the raw
footage
look at these cool dudes look how cool
these dudes are
they get the support of their parents
they have been supporting each other all
night long they want to extend an
invitation to you would you like to come
to portland oregon next weekend
alvin down in the four justin in the
three
wow this is like the movie the wizard
except like because
that's his name a lot more boring from
our man kenny up above
oh this is the final round tonight to
the 1990 nintendo world championships in
the final round
let's see the winners what skills do you
think it takes to be
excellent okay uh you have to first of
all
you can't force yourself to like the
game you just have to actually like the
game
fair enough fair enough you have to and
you have to tell yourself that you're
good enough to do it
that's a good idea okay write this down
for me i'm not writing it down you
really need
you have to have a good a brain that can
see things from like all dimensions
okay you got to be able to see things
quickly and use it and now you work at a
sunoco though right
you know you've got to be able to shell
and like
for super marios you have to look and
figure out that the exact fastest way to
do this the fastest way to do that the
best way to do this
that's what i did and it came out on top
what do you think terrible that's
terrible
well with anything you do in life i mean
if it makes decisions
better for you or quicker like it makes
you decide things quicker it helps in
school i don't even i should have had
this so early on the whole time i didn't
even think about it
it helps it helps me think quicker and
learn to manipulate ideas
and stuff like that um in in the future
i guess if i'm a game counselor hey i
can help kids
but i'd like i'd like to make games i
really like to make some games
that's what i'd like to do so i'll use
it for that great fantastic
this before like people were really
diagnosing autism
okay what is your first name
you you were very worried about him for
a while tell me lived under stress for
10 years
i'm more worried about you man what's up
with that little mustache
and then they graduated to nintendo
immediately and
i was always worried in terms of how
much time was spent because these games
oh this is perfect look at this there it
is
where the game for my overlay's from
[Music]
this is where my overlay was born look
at that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow look at that ponytail
look at that [ __ ] ponytail
that's [ __ ] sick
that is sick
look at that [ __ ] ponytail
mullet edge because the front he still
has it bangs in the front so it's like
mullet ash
it's a nice jacket i want a nintendo
jacket in that game
that's usually what's going to do you in
you'll fall off a cliff or what have you
if you want to be more specific maybe i
can help you out during after the show
over on the power walk where uh
tom and i will be over there we'll
answer some questions excellent question
we're gonna have
look at the hair all that all the hair
is amazing good
another question i know you're familiar
with a nintendo power magazine and a
certain specific comic
[Applause]
second warp whistle and super mario
brothers 3.
joey spends a lot of time look
these guys are nerds and i get it
but that jacket's pretty sick
that is a cool jack i want that jacket i
would wear that jacket today
that is a sick jacket
that is a sick jacket
i'm on the phone 0.248
0.248 one ring i think she's getting
quicker now
oh no i'm sorry there's almost all the
right numbers
stand up there i think we have it now
i'm gonna give you a clue it starts with
one
seven nine seventy nine all that work
for that
area family there we go simon
quest fans wow man right here
how many different endings it's simon's
quest
absolutely you got yourself a game boy
and the fanny pack give her a great big
hand a great job oh wow you got a free
game boy that's pretty cool
that's pretty [ __ ] cool